that's you that for you this is me Chris
Evans is dope dude run it over a car we
rehearsed it for a month if you missed
that you hit the ground at 40 miles an
hour and I have to look cool well that
did break all right G break it down for
us
all right let's show what's up guys this
is stuntmen react we are honored to be
joined by G de Silva today he's a
transformer he is black panther
he is Leonardo and Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles now you're on this small janky
couch with us oh this is a very
comfortable couch I'm glad and I got
good company so oh so he is going to
give us some insight into some of your
favorite Hollywood fight scenes today
I'm so excited let's jump in yes target
is a mobile satellite launch platform oh
yeah this is opening look you guys see
me almost half asleep on the right and
about now man we were in there is dark
then just talking I'm not doing chairs a
look at ten on my hip this was really
cool cuz he actually got to be on the
real ship I think it's a German or a
Russian ship
in Captain America straight up mergers
this person just straight up dead that
fine severed
[Music]
oh here are the big guys beefy boy
Leonard and big Bubba tight black
t-shirt gang yep Captain America knows
something's up does anyone want to get
out now let's all act like we're really
busy get busy fall into each other there
I am ha ha nice little bounce off the
glass it was fun seeing these two fight
Chris Evans is dope cuz he'll come in
and he has a dance background
he's a tap dance so he understands
rhythm and beats and fight choreography
is actually closer to dancing than it is
to actual fighting martial arts he can
just show up and be like okay show me
like six moves and he'll be like okay
all right let's do it
and comes in does the job uh hold that
eat that clay Colin is that a wire yeah
it was a wire pull it was fun that was a
cool shot and there's me sleeping on
Bubba's leg in the bottom corner knocked
out how many days of this take this was
two weeks one week of prep and then one
week of actual shooting and Tom Harper
is the stunt coordinator on this and he
looks out for everybody so we get cool
things like good thing called
adjustments it's like giving a tip it's
like gang gratuity sews it based on like
how hard of a hit you take how hard I
hate you take how hard the stunt was how
nice the coordinator is so what kind of
adjustment did you get for falling
asleep on the guy's leg
oh I got a good 500 bucks I think man
that was awesome hey you just down there
yeah I'm always down here do you not
know that no you know what else you
don't know today's sponsor that's right
today's sponsor privacy calm is cooler
than a Hollywood stunt I'm gonna tell
you guys all about him at the end of
this video and how you can get five
bucks free five bucks it's gonna be way
cooler than this scene tell you that
much
that's you that's you this is me Wow
this was scary this isn't CG that read
through you in this that was me doing it
were you on wires yes I was wow that was
terrified so that's about the eight-foot
gap to like to get to the walls I have
to jump straight out and have to use my
right hand to stop myself from swinging
around you know I'm in a couple times
yeah once that happens I'm actually
free-falling for about 30 of that then
the descender pulls in a descender is a
contraption that they use in rigging
that will decelerate your speed as you
fall down send they're starting to pull
in there and I have to look cool while I
go down not disturb Rick
it'll slow me down just enough and then
I'll let me land freely so his landing
it still has that weight it doesn't look
like the Hong Kong Crouching Tiger
Hidden Dragon I land on my tippy toes
and I can do ballet afterwards yeah
there's weight to it so they still drop
me how many takes do do for that on the
day seven but we rehearsed it about a
month and these rehearsals are you're
doing are you starting like in a gym
with their CIL's no we start here oh
really so you just have a month booked
at the spot yep
oh don't think you're not to tell us how
you do the fast friendly it's called the
magic carpet and so they have a chanted
carpet right yes and it flies yes that
you get in a secret chamber so it's
called the magic carpet it's like a
really long treadmill it gets latched on
to a back of a car and the car will pull
it at speed and then you sprint on that
the only thing going on as far as VFX
goes is them taking out yes that carpet
underneath you guys but that's all
practical you're actually called
practical we're all running we build up
speed it's so crazy we just built and
built and built we got ourselves
comfortable just running straight first
then we did changing lanes now we're
gonna do it at 15 miles an hour now
we're gonna work our way to 20 miles an
hour now we're at 40 what really cool
Gary that was that was for real that was
for real so I had to literally go jump
off the back of a car and then jump to
the next Lane as the Audi is going past
me with no track underneath that no
track underneath the Audi so I subscribe
if you missed that you hit the ground at
40 miles an hour no luckily there was a
pat thank God there was a pat behind me
the other one though it said no I'm not
doing this cuz my mom would freak out it
sounds very dangerous like it's really
respectful populated because it's their
job to make sure you don't get hurt yes
absolutely
is it true that the stuntman will do
anything but it's the stunt coordinators
job to say yes or no you should say no
if you feel uncomfortable if it's
something you've never really done
before express that this is something
you've never really done before yeah and
as a coordinator you should respect that
and find a way to get what you want
without endangering the stunt person
like how they built me up to them and
I've never been on a magic carpet before
you don't just start at a hundred miles
an hour you want to wait to 100 miles an
hour once you get into it once you get
comfortable and you're like in the
costume you're doing that you're like
yeah this is this is all insane like
this looks like a CG fest but like that
dude running over a car we rehearsed it
for months
[Applause]
I didn't think that they were gonna have
me smash through the pillar with with me
on the back and they were like no no
you're gonna be on the back of that I
was like oh cool I can see you in and
now I can like I can think you to feel
but it's only God really tightly for
dear life don't let go
did they install some like grips on
there on the back like they have like a
rating so they cut they cut a little bit
off the fender yeah and put a bar there
for me to hold on to you I feel like the
number one muscle that you work out is
your grip string I got the strongest
grip man I know for holding on for dear
life on this build hold that Wow
we did that really I remember watching
them rehearse this I was like this is
crazy I got the try that's a real
motorcycle yeah what it was magic so
it's this is wired of course they
started back like maybe 10 feet let's
say 10 oh yes when they're pulling that
guy off the wire hand pulling him and
they got another group of guys pulling
the bike up oh really oh so it's not
just swinging up it no is that something
actually wrangling the front that's he's
trying to hold it down as much as he
possibly can look he's barely holding on
he's barely holding on oh and of course
that leg stretch man oh oh you know how
often do you rip your pants and said man
I'm notorious that's that's probably one
of the first things I do in our wardrobe
fitting so I'll do the craziest most
abrupt squat motion sometimes I look
like a fool other times I'm like POW yep
I mean it's in pants
[Music]
this was fun so what they had was us on
the car pulling the motorcycle from the
front and they had it on a swivel that
will make it look like he got slapped
out pyrotech would make the explosion
happens and I jumped through the
explosion I got make a nice pretty
picture that's me
reaching full out and swiping across the
back of the wheel
this is so sick boom Adrienne you are
such a badass he steps up were real yes
so they're pulling it with wires and the
door open he runs out I was flipping my
I was going crazy on the side so the car
flipping is that in the same shot with
him jumping out the door or is that a
different different shot okay different
said that but he's still running with
the car flipping in front of them which
is so cool but luckily he's in the safer
distance what a crazy name I've never
seen this movie there's a first time
I've ever seen why yeah what is this
movie oh yeah you can catch all these
hands I've seen got a lot of critiques
from everybody you know agreed that the
scene isn't very well done but I do feel
like you can bring something to the
table that most people haven't talked
about everybody always talks about the
CG and like I was actually surprised to
find out they actually had people doing
motion capture for this cuz like they're
so fluid right I kind of wish they
hadn't
and kept it a little bit more rounded
and real because you kind of lose the
weight of the fight and that's what I
felt was like the bigness with it yeah
so there's no stakes rating aside like
you're not getting pain in this fight no
the suits are getting D materialises
getting interrupted so now we're
starting to see bits of them and it's
like okay but you don't really ever see
a fight in this aspect so there's no
bruising there's no there's no danger
until the last second which is very
abrupt like boom he should be like
mantle dismantled from that you just got
blasted and you're vibranium suit
doesn't work anymore right then they're
vulnerable
yes and you have that moment of day here
we go here now we have this dad look at
that emotion so good this knife has made
me rethink my life choices when you're
fighting in costume do you have to have
like a special costume made just for you
to fight in so that you don't like break
it yes well it breaks
regardless Luke things like will fall
off like little detailed stuff so they
have to glue it they'll have a team of
guys that are there to like do that kind
of stuff for us when I was Panther on
Civil War we only had one helmet for me
so we were very careful on that helmet
she got punched in the face by Sebastian
Stan one day I heard him say oh yeah he
punched on me he walks up he's like
y'all I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I'm like
dude it's perfectly fine the math was
there it broke all the impact we just
trying to make him feel good yeah part
of my job is to make sure the actor
feels comfortable right because you want
him to perform as best as they can I
want him to have that same energy that
he had when he actually did hit me buddy
that's a really professional attitude I
try I try me it's hot these guys are
cool because they're not there in a cool
nice studio all my fights were like in
98 degree heat in Atlanta wearing all
black I threw up a couple times man it
was rough the suit was collecting sweat
so it really so I gained weight oh I was
like oh this is a 25 pound suit now we
were shooting the airport fight and one
day they came up to me like oh you're
gonna do a 50-foot ratchet today I was
like oh cool I've never done one of
those mr. Wiggly whoo we call her
Scarlet Witch with her Wiggly whoo she
stops me and flings me into the air and
I fly into the walkway into the plane
there wasn't a walkway that was CG the
first times we were rehearsing and we
were Hurston without the suit and I was
landing like skillfully surprisingly on
my feet I was like good all right cool
we put on my my suit which is now soaked
in my sweat they're like all right ready
and
I go move they they drop me a little bit
farther than they were originally had
and I landed on concrete on my right
shoulder ah you see me struggle to get
up to a knee and be in a cool stance
[Laughter]
yeah I'm okay I did a sick stunt over
this couch just a little bit ago Angie
and Nico and Clint saw it they were so
impressed they all went out to train
well they're at it I'm gonna tell you
about today's sponsor privacy calm
that's right you see privacy calm is the
best way to protect all your
transactions online they use encryption
data to create virtual numbers for your
actual credit card numbers which means
that your credit card information will
never be stolen ever again
look me in the eyes and if you've never
had your credit card information stolen
let me know in the comments I'd love to
read some lies today guys well the
second thing you need to know you can
set spending limits and expiration dates
on your cards it's real simple you do it
all online they never charge you
interest they never charge you fees and
they never sell your data so you're good
to go all you got to do is go over to
privacy comm slash corridor crew and
you'll get five bucks just for signing
up happy they come
stop man stop man this was fun this is
super fun thanks man you guys ever want
to sell on the couch together like this
again and watch some stuff and I'm down
you can come over I got a couch just
like this and if you guys would like to
follow Aggie ask some questions anything
like that
ya can follow them on Instagram it's GX
DaSilva yes
GX DeSilva and of course if you enjoyed
the show you know please consider
subscribing and please leave a comment
for any other cool fight scenes I love
fighting some really obscure stuff
please let us know in the comments below
it's a great way to know what's out
there thanks for watching everybody
yeah thank you so much for having me
yeah thanks key okay thank you
when I first started out here I worked
on that when they gear videos it was the
rain man oh man Eric Linden actually
pulled me on and like maybe had like
maybe one film under my belt and Here I
am like seven years later it's pretty
awesome well welcome back thank you yeah
oh yeah
[Music]